this morning we are hearing from british
singer-songwriter f.k.a twigs in her
first
tv interview since filing a civil
lawsuit in december
against actor and former boyfriend shia
labeouf the singer who was also on the
cover of the next issue of l magazine
accuses la buff of sexual battery
assault and inflicting emotional
distress
he denies all of the allegations f.k.a
twigs
says she filed this lawsuit and is
speaking out to help women
in abusive relationships he would often
just start having an argument with me in
the middle of the night start accusing
me
of doing all sorts of things planning to
leave him in my head
he'd wake me up and tell me i was
disgusting that i was wild
all the things that he was accusing you
of were absolutely not true
nothing was ever true that this is the
thing but but i would really doubt
myself
you know especially when i'd like wake
up and he'd be like you were lying there
with your eyes open
planning to leave me and i'd be like i
literally was
asleep but then he would like
only want me to sleep naked because he
said if i didn't
then i was keeping myself from him so
you know it's a tactic that a lot of
abusers use it's just this like
constant availability and everything
centered
around them and i think you know that's
why i wanted to come out and talk about
this because the signs really are there
from the beginning
so when did you think maybe
there are some issues here there's a
problem there wasn't one set moment
but it's very subtle that's the thing
about
you know domestic abuse domestic
violence it's a real
gradual step-by-step process to get
somebody to a place where they lose
themselves so much
they accept or feel like they deserve to
be treated in that way
it's not one thing it's loads of tiny
little things that get sewn together
into a nightmare wow in a response to
fka twig's suit obtained by other media
outlets last week
la buff's lawyer said the actor denies
generally
and specifically each and every
allegation in the lawsuit
we reached out to la buff's attorney
that's sean holly who told us a lawyer
issuing
issuing general denials to all the
allegations in a lawsuit is standard
procedure in civil practice
and signals nothing about chia's past
statements or his acceptance of
responsibility
for things that he has done wrong
nothing has changed it was very
interesting talking to her she tells
some really eye-opening and jaw-dropping
things it's very troubling
but the thing that gets me it's her
first tv interview she said i've never
talked to a tv
reporter before she was a little nervous
but she didn't want to be talking to me
she said i tried to settle this
privately
i went to him and said you know if you
will get help if you will make a
donation to women's charities about
abuse
this will never see the light of day and
when he didn't she felt she had to speak
out you can understand why she wouldn't
want to
sit down with cameron rolling in the
lights on talk about those stories
yeah very private very painful and very
private look forward to seeing that
tomorrow yeah you can see more of our
interview with
fka twigs that's tomorrow on cbs this
morning and
here's something very important you need
to know if you need help related to
domestic violence we have free resources
on our website cbsnews.com